para algunos abdalá hand of firmó un
pacto con el [__] otros lo acusan de
haber vendido la revolución de ese 21 de
noviembre el primer ministro de ciudad
volvió a asumir el cargo en el seno del
consejo de soberanía que dirigía el
hombre que lo había derrocado casi un
mes antes el general al burhan donde más
robusto cuando acepté el cargo de primer
ministro de la transición yo sabía
perfectamente que el camino no estaría
lleno de rosas y que la ruta sería
difícil el camino y atajando finalmente
terminó ante la desconfianza de una
población cansada de los compromisos con
los militares
rechazamos toda forma de golpe de estado
incluyendo si eso implica el regreso
dejando que al gobierno nuestra gloriosa
revolución de diciembre de 2018 tuvo
lugar para conseguir un gobierno civil
en su totalidad
abdalá cuando fue nombrado primer
ministro de la transición representaba
esperanza nació en 1956 en el sur del
país es un economista que trabajó en
naciones unidas no se encontraba en
ciudad en el momento de la revolución
rechazó el cargo de ministro de finanzas
que omar al bashir le había propuesto en
2018 con la del dictador en abril de
2019 las autoridades de transición
heredaron un país en quiebra abdalá
cuando fue depuesto por los militares el
pasado 25 de octubre junto con los otros
miembros civiles de su ejecutivo bajo el
pretexto de no haber podido frenar esta
crisis económica pero los sudaneses no
quisieron ceder y el regreso dejando en
el consejo soberano levantó voces
discordantes las manifestaciones no
cesaron pese a la represión de la junta
en el poder
[Aplausos]